the independent inquiry into child sex
abuse has criticized what it's described
as the blatant hypocrisy of religions
purporting to teach right from wrong but
failing to respond to child sexual abuse
the inquiry found abuse in most
religious settings with some having no
child protection policies in place
the report released in the last few
minutes examined evidence received from
38 religious organizations in england
and wales
as many as
000 children receive receive some form
of supplementary schooling from a faith
organization in the uk
but of the 446 places of worship only 37
had up-to-date criminal checks on staff
who worked regularly with children
the inquiry also revealed that 10 of sex
abuse suspects investigated between
early 2015 and january 2020 were linked
to a religious organization
let's speak to our correspondent ali
fordeski who's in the newsroom for us
this afternoon a damning report ali yeah
it is more uncomfortable reading worth
saying that there had been previous
reports into the christian and
protestant traditions so this is
separate from that but as you say it
looked at 38 different religious
institutions including judaism islam
hinduism buddhism
the jehovah's witness community and it
found as you say that in all major uk
religions there had been child abuse it
talked about it but the blatant
hypocrisy of these
religious institutions that were meant
to be teaching children about right and
wrong instead failing to protect
children it said there had been
significant failings and as it put it
blatant hypocrisy and these were
organizations that played a central role
in the lives of millions of children it
talked about a number of different case
studies including the three
nine-year-old children who'd been abused
while they were being taught the koran
the the seven-year-old child who'd been
abused by his sunday school teacher at
home after his mother died who no one in
the church would believe or help and it
said that so often in these institutions
the reputation of the religion had been
prioritized over
the protection of children it said that
there had been complex reasons why abuse
had been allowed to happen but often
there had been cultural barriers and
that um that sexuality hadn't been able
to be talked about openly and of course
over the last few days we have also been
covering allegations from the jehovah's
witness community about elders not
acting against child abuse and not
not going to the authorities with
allegations of sexual abuse in their
community so it does make a number of
recommendations including that ofsted
which is a school's watchdog has greater
powers within all of these religious
contexts and that all these religious
institutions have a policy in place for
protecting children it said that so
often at the moment those policies
simply weren't in place and crucially it
says in reality the scale of this
problem is likely to be much bigger uh
that than they were able to find
and that there is likely to be a
significant under-reporting of child
sexual abuse within these religious
contexts